heute am mittwoch ist österreich bei
einfluss von einer störungszone welche
uns wird man sehen kann hier in zeltweg
reichlich bewölkung bringt und immer
wieder niederschläge mit sich bringt das
wird heute den ganzen tagesverlauf
anhalten und erst am späten abend
beziehungsweise morgen am vormittag
abziehen jetzt ist natürlich für die
besucher der erbauer interessant
freitag/samstag gewitter das wetter
werden muss ich eine regenjacke mit
jemand nein regenjacke ist nicht nicht
vonnöten da diese störungszone am
donnerstag sich richtung osten weiter
begibt und am sonntag freitag mit
nebelfeldern zu rechnen ist und dann bei
wolken den ganzen tag über die sicht
nicht verdecken aber die der show kein
abbruch mit sich bringt und am samstag
dann mit leicht öligen verhältnissen
gute verhältnisse vorzufinden sind das
die stadt würde vielleicht nicht reichen
das einkommen kühlere verhältnisse mit
sich also ein pullover sicher von nöten
aber die regenjacke kann man zu hause
lassen